[Music]
hi everyone I'm Anu and in this video
we're going to show you how the latest
breakthroughs in AI are changing the
user experience of personalization and
recommendations and media platforms we
know that many users feel that finding
content is too difficult in typical
Media Services
so first let's review the current
challenges for media platforms
in a report published by Deloitte it
says that over 50 percent of the Gen Z
audience canceled a streaming service
within the last six months
other reports indicate that 81 of
viewers as streaming services expect
highly personalized recommendations
personalization and recommendations are
crucial factors in the success of media
platforms to address these challenges
Google is bringing the latest AI
technology to Media platform customers
to redefine the industry standard with
recommendations AI for media so in short
this product is all about making Media
Services sticky AKA strong retention
Stars was one of the first companies to
introduce recommendations AI into their
media platforms star saw a 40
Improvement in engagement rate and a 70
increase in completion ratio
Newsweek another customer saw a 10
increase in subscription rate and a 10
increase in total revenue per visit now
you may be wondering what's the
difference between Google cloud-powered
recommendations and traditional
recommendations how can it drive
engagement and retention
so to understand that let's take a
deeper dive into how Google AI takes an
Innovative approach to recommendation
systems with a type of deep learning
model called Transformers
media recommendations are all about
predicting which videos or content each
user will be interested in
traditional recommendation systems look
at the user's past clicks and purchase
history to find other users who have
clicked or purchased similar items this
information can then be used to make
predictions about which items a user is
likely to be interested in this is
called collaborative filtering but the
challenge of collaborative filtering is
that it doesn't recognize what the user
is up to right now so what kind of video
is a user interested now not last week
or last month the user's mood is ever
changing and you need to follow it also
traditional recommendation systems can't
sense the steps in the user's
decision-making process are they looking
for any new or trending videos trying to
find a particular type of video or about
to purchase a specific video
Transformers are a deep learning
technology invented by Google
researchers in 2017 providing
outstanding performance and
understanding meaning from data
for example if you pass an input text
math practice books for adults to a
Transformer it predicts that the word
books is the most important and how the
other words are related to it so it
finds books about math practice and
books for adults
then from the vast space of different
kinds of books the Transformer can spot
the area to find math practice books for
adults
this is the capability of Transformer
understanding the meaning from data and
it improves the experience of Google
search significantly
Transformers outstanding ability is the
foundation of the big AI Innovation we
see today such as a smooth conversations
with AI chatbots and the Deep text
understanding by large language models
now Google brings a Transformers
Innovation to solve the challenges of
media platforms through recommendations
AI
recommendations AI uses Transformer
technology to understand user Behavior
such as viewing a page clicking a link
starting or stopping a video
by looking at these user activities the
Transformer understands the
relationships of these selected items
what they mean and what the user is up
to right now
so it can predict the next best possible
item to recommend in real time
the user experience of recommendations
AI is just like having a professional
concierge who deeply understands what
your past favorites are and what you're
looking for now
with this Innovative user experience
Media Services can be more sticky for
millions of users recommendations AI
offers several major benefits first
increasing retention and conversion with
state-of-the-art AI for intelligent
real-time personalization second it's an
out of the box solution with easy
integration with existing it systems and
Google tools such as Google analytics
and Google tag manager no AI expertise
is required for the implementation
third it is a fully managed service with
high scalability and availability so the
required operational resources are
minimal
fourth your data is secured and will be
only used to improve your
recommendations so that's the secret
ingredient of recommendations Ai and the
reason why customers such as stars and
Newsweek saw significant impact on their
businesses
now let's take a look at how a
recommendations AI is organized and how
you can get started with your media
platform recommendations AI can be
integrated with your media platform in
three simple steps
first import your data Google provides
codeless ways to integrate your existing
catalog data and user events no large
system integration is required this step
may take one to two weeks
second customize
recommendations AI is easy to tailor to
your own business rules no data or
infrastructure or expertise is required
this step may take a week
third deliver anywhere recommendations
AI can be easily leveraged across web
pages mobile apps and other touch points
with users this step takes about four
weeks but can be started in parallel
with step one
the first step is to import your data
there are two types of data you need to
import your catalog and user events
there are multiple ways to import this
data so for example if you're already
using Google analytics or Google tag
manager you can easily import the
existing user events from them you can
also choose from a variety of other
methods such as bigquery Google Cloud
Storage the API or JavaScript Snippets
the second step is to customize
recommendations AI to fit your specific
needs you can choose from three
recommendation types so we will now show
shortly
you can also identify your objective and
apply various filtering rules and
configurations for example you can
choose to optimize for click-through
rate click and play rate or watch time
you can also filter recommendations by
item availability price or other
criteria so four recommendation types we
have three models the first model is
recommended for you this is suitable for
category or home pages and shows a
personalized selection of items within
one or multiple categories
the second model is more like this this
is suitable for item detail pages to
show similar items to the current item
with personalized selection
the third model is others you may like
this is suitable for item detail pages
to help users explore relevant popular
and diversified items in the media
service across multiple categories
recommendations AI models can be easily
created on the console first import the
item data from bigquery or Google Cloud
Storage next import the user activity
events now you can create a model by
entering a model name
choosing a model type and business
objective the model will be trained
after that you can configure a server to
start the integration
let's summarize what we learned today
recommendations AI for media is
specifically designed to enable the next
generation of media experiences at its
core it uses Transformer models to
understand each user's interests and
intentions and makes recommendations in
real time
this makes the media experience like
having a personal concierge and yet it's
so easy to integrate with your existing
systems and does not require any AI
expertise
to get started visit the discovery AI
page on cloud.google.com
foreign
[Music]